[Music]
aquaman the first solo movie of the king
of atlantis was released in 2018 and has
since become the most successful dc film
of all time with box office takings of
1.1 billion us dollars it quickly became
clear that a second part was in the
making and this year at last the time
has come aquaman and the lost kingdom
will be released in theaters however
there's still many questions surrounding
the plot that's why we sat down and
summarized everything important about it
for you guys based on some of the
statements made by the producers it is
possible to figure out quite a bit of
the storyline
in case you don't remember exactly what
the first film was about here's a little
recap if you haven't seen the movie yet
and want to avoid spoilers you should
skip ahead to the next chapter author
curry is born as the son of atlanta the
queen of elendis and thomas curry half
human half atlantean he is eligible to
ascend the throne of atlantis even
though he has no interest in doing so
for a long time yet one year after the
events surrounding justice league his
half-brother orm decides to unite the
six underwater kingdoms and start a war
against the humans who've been polluting
the world's oceans for decades wanting
to stop him arthur challenges him in a
duel for the crown which he loses and
only barely escapes with his life he
only manages to survive with the help of
the fighter mera the two set out to find
the trident of atlan the first king of
atlantis whose owner is the ruler of all
seas in order to prevent this orm sends
the pirate david kane alias black manta
on them the latter has a score to settle
with arthur since he believes aquaman to
be responsible for the death of his
father he fails however and so arthur
and mera find a wormhole in the depth of
the ocean of the trench which takes them
to the hidden sea in the center of the
earth there they discover not only the
trident but also arthur's mother who was
presumed dead and was sacrificed to the
trench by the atlanteans together with
the trident and a huge army of sea
creatures they now face orm and his
hosts this time around aquaman wins but
spares the life of his half-brother
after he promises to support him upon
learning that his mother is still alive
in the end atlanta returns to artha's
father at the surface while arthur and
mera ascend to the throne
there are constantly fresh news about
the cast of course we know of many
familiar actors who will again play an
important role but also interesting new
ones are being announced over and over
again among them is someone who was
already considered a terror of the seas
in other series
it's a given that jason momoa will once
again take on the role of arthur curry
aka aquaman he was certainly partly
responsible for the success of the first
movie which clearly stood out from the
otherwise rather weak dc eu film
adaptions especially when you see the
portrayals of aquaman in the comics but
more makes a successful change he will
also be joined by amber hurt and the
role of mera she will surely have a lot
to do in order to help him out of some
of his troubles further confirmed is
nicole kidman as queen atlanta and star
wars star tamara morrison as thomas
curry what kind of importance their
roles will have however is not yet clear
else's half-brother orm known as ocean
master is also back he will of course be
played by patrick wilson again whether
he finds that aquaman's side as promised
or forges his own plans is something we
will probably only see on the big screen
we have also already seen a villain in
the mid-credit scene of the first part
namely aya abdul madin ii is david kane
better known as black manta likewise
returning as dolph lundgren as king
nerius the father of mira he had joined
orm for much of the first film but
switched sides when he saw aquaman with
the first king's trident atlan the king
of atlantis was previously introduced as
a character but has been recast he sang
the city thousands of years ago in an
accident went into exile afterwards in
the previous sequences he was played by
grey mctavish now however vincent regan
has taken over the part we doubt that he
will have a big role we rather suspect
for the flashbacks like in the first
part
as we could already see in the mid
credit scene there is a new villain
namely dr steven shin played by randall
park in the scene he pulls the half dead
david cain out of the sea when kane
wakes up he is already in shin's lap
shin demands to know where atlantis is
and promises black manta to help him
with his revenge in exchange for the
information this steven shin should not
be too unknown to the comic readers
among you in fact in the comics he's a
friend of arthur and his father however
it results in a break after the two are
unwilling to reveal anything about
atlantis to the scientist also to appear
is karshan the tiger shark which mutated
in an atomic explosion and is actually
considered an adversary of green lantern
how big the roll will be or whether the
villain is only being teased is
unfortunately not yet known the shark is
played by india moore who is known from
the us series pose
but arthur curry won't have to face all
the baddies alone a new hero will also
make his debut we are talking about
stingray who is a member of the light
brigade in the comics the new hero will
be played by yan xiao who is still
relatively unknown in hollywood the
portuguese actress has previously
appeared mostly in local productions are
the more reason to look forward to her
debut in hollywood and her new role in
the dc eu
however there's another newcomer we are
most excited about and that is none
other than euron greyjoy actor pilo
asbeck he has already sailed this season
game of thrones and is known there as a
notorious sailor he's one of the few
actors for whose role not even the name
is known however we hope to see him back
in his old manner namely as a scoundrel
and a womanizer he's already
demonstrated that this kind of role
really suits him
already shortly after the release of the
first part a second one was announced by
dc in january 2020 the release date was
set for december 2022 with james juan
and david leslie johnson writing the
script and directing as they did in the
first part even before filming began
there was a wild discussion about the
role of mera amber heard was alleged to
have falsified evidence in a trial with
johnny depp and as a result a petition
with 1.6 million signatures was
submitted that the road should be recast
one name that was read time and time
again was emilia clarke in the end
though the cast remained the same as in
the first movie with the beginning of
the pandemic the start of shooting for
aquaman the lost kingdom was also
delayed but the team still managed to
complete the film and the allotted time
so that so far at least the release date
has not been postponed the premiere is
expected to be on december 16 2022
unfortunately not much is known about
this storyline yet we are eagerly
waiting for the first trailer thus the
story we're describing is pure theory
and not confirmed by anyone based on the
title a possible plot can be put
together anyways as the title and the
lost kingdom already reveals it is about
well lost kingdom it might be possible
that this very kingdom is not atlantis
but some other kingdom perhaps dr steven
shin stumbled upon it during his
research on the underwater city and
discovered former enemies of atlantis
together with kane he could now go in
search of this civilization in order to
bring them back into a war with atlantis
p we aspect who could possibly leave the
alien kingdom might also play a major
role according to james 1 aquaman 2 is
supposed to be spookier again the last
kingdom could possibly be located in the
depth of the trench kingdom after all
that's where the portal to atlantis
trident was situated it is also
conceivable that arthur will not be able
to fight against this force on his own
and will seek help from his brother the
letter seems to have reformed after
learning that their mother is still
alive if black man is serious about his
revenge it might also be a possibility
that he hunts down aquaman's father in
this way he would pay off a bag in kind
since he believes him to be responsible
for his father's death what all this
will really look like is something we
will all find out in december the
excitement is definitely there already
alright that's it everyone that was all
the information we got about aquaman 2
which newcomer are you looking forward
to the most and what role do you want
pillow aspect to play let us know in the
comments if you don't want to miss any
news around aquaman until the premiere
be sure to subscribe to our weekly movie
news see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]